All right, listen, guys, I've been debating
whether or not to do this segment over the
weekend because I don't want to no one confuse
people.
I don't want to spread wrong information.
I don't want to say something that might get
somebody to take a risky behavior or to put
people at risk of catching Corona virus. But
at the same time, it wouldn't be honest for
me to keep this information from you and not
to tell you about it and not to get your thoughts
on it. So I am coming to you today not to
tell you that I know what's going on with
lockdowns versus state reopening, but merely
to tell you there are clearly things going
on that we don't understand, or at least that
I don't understand. I won't speak for others,
but I'll tell you that I don't understand.
Let me give you an example. California has
been closed for months. Texas reopened in
late April. Their curves for cases and deaths
are looking very, very similar. And again,
please understand, I'm not saying anything
about lockdowns or reopening. I'm making no
medical or economic claims. I am merely saying
something is not making sense and I don't
know what it is. And I want to be super careful
because I want to learn what it is that's
going on. So let's look at California and
Texas. California and Texas ordered lockdowns
right around the same time. It was about March
20th. From what we saw, California's lockdown
was more strict than that in Texas. And California's
lockdown seemed to be taken more seriously
by people in California than the Texas lockdown
was taken by people living in Texas. The California
lockdown has now been going on two months.
Texas mostly started reopening on April twenty
eighth, I believe it was. We're going to put
the cases up on the screen. Now, there is
no doubt that if you look back to early May,
the Texas cases have started to climb at a
modest rate. And indeed, when you look at
raw numbers, Texas has had some of its higher
single day new case numbers over the last
week or 10 days. But the curve is not very
different in Texas than it is in California,
where you look at California, which has been
on lockdown for two full months now. They
also are starting to see some of their highest
case numbers in the last week. So I want to
be thorough here. I I can imagine explaining
this in a bunch of different ways. So let
me give you one example. Have the states simply
been ramping up testing? And Texas has been
ramping up testing by more than California.
So the increased cases are merely a result
of testing more? Well, to some degree, that's
true. Both California and Texas are testing
more now than they were at the start of the
lockdown. So to some degree, you could say
both California and Texas are seeing more
cases because they are testing more. But how
does a state that's been on a lockdown for
two months have an almost identical curve,
not raw numbers, but an almost identical curve
to a state that's been open for three weeks?
I don't know. I don't pretend to understand.
Now, could it be that in Texas, even though
they're open, people are still doing a lockdown?
And in California, even though they're still
locked down, more people are ignoring the
lockdown? I don't know. I don't pretend to
know what if we look at deaths instead of
cases? Once again, it looks similar. The curves
are similar. California has had way more deaths
in the aggregate. California also has more
deaths per capita. California was an early
hotspot. It has more flights to Asia. More
people coming back and forth from Asia has
a bigger population. But when we look at the
curve, the shape of the curve, we are seeing
relatively high numbers of deaths in California
about a plateau. And it's not that different
in Texas. Texas had its highest death numbers,
but a couple of weeks ago, California had
them about four weeks ago. So I don't pretend
to know what is going on, but I want to try
to think through some of the ideas I already
mentioned. The case numbers are affected by
testing. Maybe the curves are similar because
testing has ramped up similarly and it's not
reflective of real case numbers. That's a
possibility. That's a possibility. Then you
look at deaths, though, and the curves look
similar. So maybe the deaths haven't yet peaked
in Texas and California's have peaked are
in a slow decline. And right now, they're
kind of crossing. OK, that's possible. Maybe
we'll know that in another 10 or 14 days.
Another argument I saw, maybe Texas is simply
lying. Right. OK. I mean, listen, I don't
put it past them, but in order to hide case
and death numbers while putting out fake testing
numbers or maybe the testing numbers are real,
then that would mean that the deaths and testing
and deaths in cases are out of proportion.
It's a coordinated conspiracy. So I don't
listen. We heard Florida was at one point
hiding cause of death. It's a pretty big conspiracy,
and I don't know that Texas is even competent
enough to get away with it. Is it possible
the heat is a factor? Well, it's hot in a
lot of California as well, and it has been
for several months. Do the lockdowns not work?
I mean, we have information that show lockdowns
do reduce case numbers and deaths in the aggregate.
But is it possible that there's a natural
curve, that some kind of natural timing to
the virus that has a similar trajectory regardless
of policy, the lockdown saves people in numbers.
But the trajectories end up being similar?
I don't know. I truly don't know. There was
one paper that suggested that. Again, I mentioned.
Is it possible that even though California
has stricter lockdown and Texas has reopened,
maybe Californians are ignoring it and some
Texans are staying home and it's sort of evening
out? Is there evidence of that? I don't know.
I have no idea. What about maybe I'm cherry
picking by only looking at California and
Texas? Okay. Let's compare to other states,
New Jersey and Florida. New Jersey is part
of the big New York hotspot and the big New
York lockdown. Florida famously started re-opening
stuff weeks ago. The trajectories for cases
in Florida and New Jersey are also very similar.
Certainly Florida hasn't seen the same recent
decline that New Jersey had, but they both
went down for a bit and they've both popped
recently. Could it just be testing? Well,
maybe, but it's still a similar trajectory.
Looking at deaths in New Jersey and Florida,
it's a very similar curve now, to be super
clear. The numbers are different. The death
numbers in Jersey are way higher. They were
an early hotspot, but the curves are similar
with similar timing. So, you know, I never
lie to you. I've noticed this. I'm bringing
it to you and I want to know more. Now, the
answer could be. Every place is doing poorly
because of the disastrous federal response.
We have no national contact tracing in place.
So even the lockdowns only help a little bit.
I don't know. I don't have the answer, but
this is the data that I'm seeing. I want to
hear from you. What do you think is going
on here?